Oh
so today we'll have Vincent van der Gaal
from them okay and he'll be talking
about visualizing data through pandas
takeaway so hi everyone first things
first we will need a bit of software to
get all this working make sure at least
that you have ipython notebook you can
easily get it probably becoming an
account of distribution is the easiest
to get if you don't have already go to
this website I will have an opinionated
talk about how you want to visualize
things and my personal opinion is that
the best floating library out there at
this moment is from the r programming
language in this talk I will also show
you how easy it is to port the data
frame from pandas to R so you can still
have the best of both worlds if you want
to do the plotting exercises as well
please go to the our studio website and
get that downloaded during this talk we
will also use a couple of CSV files you
can find those on my blog HTTP slash
slash coning com
having said this my name is Vincent I'm
a data scientist go data driven I've
Dutch and the United States background
is where I used to live before joining
this company it was a independent
contractor of programming and I was a
former lecturer of calculus and
statistics at a couple universities in
Holland my current stack includes a lot
of Hadoop there is getting bigger and
bigger so we need to put it on clusters
I do a lot of things for the front end
cuz clients like to see data and still
the main things I do are either done in
R or in Python or I should say Python is
really really taking over the ecosystem
there used to be a time when our was the
main thing you'd go to more and more
Python has really been taking over
everything again make sure you're
downloading these things my talk will
mainly focus on learning the basics of
pandas pumice is a very nice
domain-specific language to deal with
data frames and data in general and I
will also try to convey the basics of
visualization done through digi plot and
I will also talk about how you can
combine the two part of this talk will
be slightly theoretical feda will use
the slides the other part of the talk
will be done by an eye Python notebook I
will
do it as slow as I can so you can type
along don't worry everything that we
will see today will be available after
the talk on my blog so analyzing data I
do a lot of work for a lot of clients so
I've been at two banks I've been at the
Dutch airport I've done two airline
companies and I've seen two online
retailers and basically the things you
really notice is that data is the main
specific thing whenever we're doing
stuff of data I like to be able to see
what my colleagues are doing and so I
can compare data I really like things
that are quick and flexible I don't like
waiting an hour for a query I don't like
it when a program need to start off
because there's a huge C C file in it I
noticed that there are a lot of similar
steps when I'm doing things with data so
usually I want to see the mean or the
average per geographic group per gender
per time of day these are all sort of
things I do on a day to day basis and we
need those things to be quick but I do
notice that I'm doing the exact same
thing constantly which brings me to the
point I really like to do that don't
repeat yourself principle a lot also I
really prefer typing to mouse clicking
in general the main conclusion is that
we really shouldn't be using Excel
anymore
and most companies actually still do use
Excel it's kind of ridiculous if you go
to the insurance companies of Holland
and these are people who are talking
billions and billions of dollars they
still tend to use Excel one excel sheet
gets passed at another guy someone
changes a formula in one cell messes the
whole thing up it's just not a pretty
thing so we need some different tools
and Python is a great programming
language so let's try to do something
with Python do you guys know big data
blow out it's a it's a guy on Twitter he
actually writes pretty funny but good
stuff about big data
technically in data science 80% of the
time we are preparing data and 20% of
the time we are spending to complain
about needs to prepare the data most of
the time we actually end up doing is to
prepare data so my talk will focus in on
this because when you have the right
tools instead of feeling this it'll feel
a bit more like this to put it quite
bluntly so we're not gonna do Excel
announces we're going to be a bit more
of a programming else so why would you
want to do
besides the fact that we can aggressive
with data nowadays python is a very
flexible language you can do networking
with it you can build websites with it
you can do scaling with us anything so
having a language I could do all of
these things basically means you have to
learn less which is a good thing the
community is very large nowadays there
are a lot of libraries like none pilar
we can use so performance is not
necessarily a burden and the main thing
that people tend to like about
heightened is it tends to be written
quickly so I can write a couple of lines
of Python and someone else can
immediately understand it we actually
are at a time where I am more expensive
as a person than the huge server that
I'm using so if I can write an app
within a day instead of in a week that's
actually worth quite a lot of value so
these are all good reasons to use Python
also for data analysis for this we're
going to use pandas for those of you
that have not already gotten the
notebook there are two ways of
installing pandas the easiest way is to
just use Pip do note that from the
notebook should you have a different
python version or using virtual
environments you can also just start
your python session import the pip
library and just call a function that
within your own python environment will
install on those for you
so the theory about pomace basically
pongas is just one object that we're
continuously talking to so instead
having a like matrix like a numpy array
within a numpy array think of it more as
an actual excel sheet but then in an
object form technically pomace is not
about the animal it's about a panel data
structure which according to the dots
defined is a two dimensional sized
mutable potentially heterogeneous
tabular data structure with labeled axes
basically an excel sheet that has rows
and columns every column has its own
type and the roast is basically say how
many things are in the column the nice
abstraction about this is that I can
perform operations either per column or
per roam or both so enough talk to know
we just start doing the code this is my
simple notebook and the first thing that
I always do is make sure that I have
everything installed it I need I'm
assuming everyone has installed
the UH Nocona distribution so everything
should be already installed just to play
it safe
can anyone everyone just check if these
two operations work just import numpy
import panels if these two things work
most of the rest of the training should
go fine yes okay so everyone is sort of
confirmed we can import these libraries
okay there you can ignore this for now
this is basically just the fact that I
can show these images in my Python
notebook we will get back to the
visualization bit with numpy we can
basically create an array of numbers so
what I've done here is I've just said
well there's this thing called a which
is just a bunch of random numbers
there's this thing called B it's just a
bunch of random numbers and then I have
this list and this list is basically
either full or bar also just random and
I can print these and I can see that
I've actually gotten three numpy arrays
sort of a confirmed nod everyone has
done this at this moment at any point in
the training feel free to raise your
hand if I'm going too fast by the way
I'm assuming everyone at least did this
we can sort of see these arrays that
we've just created as separate columns
where every index of the array can be
seen as a row in that one column in that
case we would have the column name a we
would have the column name B we have the
column name C but we can both see this
as maybe a dictionary and an excel sheet
this is basically the thing that the
pandas library does for you the only
thing you have to do to create a pandas
object is to have these arrays each
array needs to be converted into a
series object and those series objects
are then put into a dictionary could
everyone please just make sure that they
have done this everyone can see this by
the way right
what you can then do if you have such an
object is you can then print it before
going on I would just like to make sure
that we are actually making something
different than a numpy array so if I
print the series object which is in the
dictionary
notice that I have some sort of Road
numbering occurring and some values I
also seem to have a D type it's telling
me this is a floating number if I look
back up at the original array it didn't
give me this information so I am
actually getting back a different object
the idea is that what pennis will do is
it will index your numpy array or array
or what have you
and it will use that index to perform
optimized grouping whenever you're doing
things with data I think that's exactly
what I've written down here a thing to
keep in mind pandas will always keep
track of the type in the series this
means that if you have a series of
strings it will do different things to
it and if you have a series of floats
from numbers this is quite you normal if
you think about if you want to summarize
data you cannot do a mean of a list of
strings for example and promise keep
track service so you can see that here
if I try to make a new series object and
it has a string of a string of a float
and a number the D type will be an
object because pandas is not really able
to do anything with it
the only thing then left to do if you
want to make a data frame is just say
well we take that dictionary and we put
that into the constructor with this
we're actually constructing an instance
of a data frame object and again this is
the library this is the data frame
function and it expects some sort of a
dictionary yes okay
now the nice thing about a Python
notebook
I can print this but I can also just
choose to show it note now that I have
actual HTML table which views quite
nicely and if I just print it it will
actually show me the standard output
that you would get from a Python shell
ipython notebook has some very nice
little magical features that communicate
very well with pandas it might be good
to know that pandas is actually one of
the most useful packages in the world
simply because it removes the need for
Excel I will come back to this later but
do note that there's a couple of magic
things that happen between pandas and
the ipython notebook sometimes oh great
we've created our first data frame
object so let's go and ask it some
simple queries just a recap we started
out with just a couple of arrays each
array is represented as its own column
and each index represents a row I have
paid attention that these three arrays
are of equal length that way if I put it
in a dictionary and then put that into a
constructor for a data frame object it
gives me no errors if the row numbers
weren't the same will give me an error
so it's an excel sheet
great so how about we just select one
column and we can do that by just do
using the object notation because it's
data frame is an object and within the
object we have this object called a this
a is a series object now this data frame
also behaves a bit like a dictionary so
what I've done now is I've asked a
column from the data frame object style
what I can also do is I can ask a column
from a data frame dictionary style and
it returns to me the same thing
yes it is my personal preference to use
the object style the only reason for
this is because it's less characters but
use whatever you feel fit the only thing
I will recommend you do is that you keep
your notation consistent through your
entire document this is also very nice
if you're communicating with different
clients of different people use your
ipython notebook this column does still
behave like an umpire a so if I want to
add 10 to this column I can just say
plus 10 what you are probably already
sort of realizing is that usually when
you have Excel you have to write your
own function you will have to say well
take that column and Plus that some
function of that column I can do that
with panels as well I could even
multiply this by two and it wouldn't
complain whatsoever I can also just add
a different column and because this is a
small number you hardly see the
difference now you would the moment that
will give me an error is when I try to
add a vector that is text because text
addition with number addition doesn't
really match up just like in normal
Python you'll get an error what I could
even do if I'd really want to it's
suppose I want to define a new column
such as syntax would immediately work so
it's very Excel like but the positive
characteristics are I see a step by step
Python notebook of everything that's
been done and if I ever get a new CSV
file from the server each of these steps
get repeated without any human contact
so it is very little margin for error
margin it's very little possibility for
error I should say but we can also do is
we can convert this list to a boolean
list so if we yes
this works to try it with this does this
but this didn't as I can see it exists
now so I am accessing the same thing but
how about if I just say this then mmm No
look at it the number has changed like
this let's do it like this yes so let's
check it for existence you're right okay
thanks this is new to me so I've learned
something from this and if I do this it
should work I suppose yeah okay so I
will delete this comment simply to keep
it in line with the rest of the talk we
should use a dictionary stop good
comment Thanks still what we can do is
we can create a boolean list and this
boolean list is kind of useful what you
can do is you can pass such a bully in a
list to back to the original data frame
and notice that this boolean list cans
in some regard be seen as a dictionary
that map's of row number to a boolean
value basically what we can done and say
is hey data frame remember those rows we
had well this row should is false so
don't list this this row is false so
don't list it ah this one is true so
keep that in mind so for those of you
are familiar with excel as you say SQL
you have the Select statement select
star from
and then the where basically this is the
eponymous equivalent of it you create
such a boolean list and for every value
where it says to you can get a return
value from it so everyone try this out
real quick
these values are random so don't worry
if the exact order of true and false
isn't the same in your computer as it is
in mine but which you should be able to
confirm is that this number I think this
number is below zero so this would be
true this numbers below zero yes these
things should be equivalent yes
so I ever done take this true/false list
and give that back to the data frame it
will actually do a sub Select for me
yes yes
so you have these numpy raised right
what I then did I put everything in a
dictionary and once everything was in
that dictionary I then basically said
pandas dataframe and gave her the
dictionary could you confirm if this
falls this works for you
yes oh sorry yes this is how I define T
beforehand and again these a B and C
objects they are arrays that I've
instantiated
it's okay if I go Wanda where's this
smoking couple yes good okay
so we have this boolean list and we gave
it to the data plane everyone can
probably confirm that you get a shorter
data frame back right
the nice thing about this syntax is I
could put any sort of boolean list thing
here which can also be a combination of
multiple boolean lists the data frame
will only eventually say well if it's a
moment there's a list plus a list plus a
list is going to get combined into a
single list with an statements so that
means that you can make arbitrarily
complex filters based on any sort of
column based on any sort of row
completely flexible in it so you can all
confirm by doing this
yeah no not technically
so this is a series of that it's kind of
like I'm on my way
so let's see this operation this gets
turned into a new series of Genesis
through possible possible boxes but
every moment America defaults and this
is something this is like the series
object and basically what I'm saying
here for those subjects a new series
okay so what I can I can actually show
you this it's it's pretty much this so
this is a true/false list this is a
different true/false list but if I
combine them together like this it's
still one true/false list and this one
true/false list well that is I
eventually gonna get past in here so as
far as the data frame is concerned what
comes out of this that might be good to
say is a new pandas dataframe so I've
not changed the original data frame
object the only thing that happened was
I got a new data frame object what you
can do afterwards
once you have such a thing because it's
a normal data frame as we saw before you
can get a new column back from this one
data frame so this was our original data
frame object now I'm just saying well
just give me back the G column for
example works just like this so we can
see that most of the SQL like things
that we're doing right now can also be
done in pandas a nice aspect of this the
data frame is actually kept in memory
technically because everything that
python runs as an object is also kept in
memory this whole data frame object will
also be in memory that means that it's
blazingly fast for doing these queries
tomorrow my colleague Giovanni will give
a talk
on how you can actually use pondless as
a database as well if your interest is
only to retrieve data based on some
complex queries you can and maybe should
use pumice for it okay so these are
basically the SQL type queries that we
can do it so the from where statements
we've done pandas also shines in more
custom methods so what one could do is
just like in the bash command you can
ask for the head of a document to get
the first five lines you can do the same
thing with pandas look at the first five
rows of your data frame
everyone can confirm this and there's a
variable here so if you want to see the
only the first row that's possible as
well same thing goes for the tail if you
quickly want to go out and check what
sort of CSV you've just loaded in this
can be very useful tool other things you
might want to know include maybe the
shape maybe you want to describe the
entire data set you can do that as well
what I've shown you guys here is the
minimum the maximum all the quadrants
and the standard deviation in count of
what I have in my data frame and the
extra nice thing is if I have a data
frame then I can also pass it along a
like an apply function so I have my
original data frame I'm saying that I
want to get the mean per column but I do
the same thing also for the rows
okay a quick thing about time series so
this will be going a little bit faster
don't try to type along with this is
just the show features the person who
made this library is called West
McKinney and West McKinney was working
at in New York at the time for a couple
of financial institutions so when he
first made this it was actually made in
mind for time series analysis what I
have here and you can find this dataset
on my blog is just some financial
information this is the stock open high
and closing values I think for Apple or
some like that
I can show the first two rows and I know
that it has an index of numbers here but
it also has a date
Thomas is relatively flexible and what
it can accept as a index so instead of
giving it an index of just a number like
a row number you would expect from a
sequel database you can also just give
it a date and if you do that they can do
very intelligent things so when loading
in data you have to be mindful because
the data can have headers if I give it a
index column and tell it to parse dates
suddenly you will notice that the date
has become the index no longer is the
simple number does the date will not be
the index and if I just select one
column you will see that all of these
numbers are indexed on the date which
also means that if I want to aggregate I
can quickly do that based on the date
instead of anything else so again don't
even try to type along this is a little
bit too fast I'm sure I get the data
frame that I've just opened I check the
open price and I choose to resample the
entire data frame per week and per week
I want to see the mean and the variance
and instantly without any effort
whatsoever I get this which is a nice
data frame that basically tells me the
mean of every closing time per week
imagine doing this in Excel right a
small small thing by the way at the end
you see enum basically what means is I'm
also calculating the variance per week
in this one week when we had one data
point and a variance of only one data
point doesn't exist
I do think pandas handles this quite
nicely as well the nice thing also is I
basically said well I won't have the
mean and the variance
I can also resample per month and what I
can even do is basically give it my own
function if I write any function that
can take a data frame in it we'll apply
it so if I take the original data frame
and also ask it to sample per month and
the show the size of data that we have
per month it will do it without any
problems whatsoever the time series of
course really really is fast in this
library definitely check it out
especially if you're into financial data
or any time series whatsoever and these
days have been done by date you can also
make timestamps that are based on
milliseconds so if even if you're
interested in say sensor data this can
be me like immensely powerful for you to
use this does bring me to a certain
subject that we see a lot when applying
data science is I'm resampling so I'm
regrouping my data and then I'm applying
some sort of function on it and then I'm
bringing that all together in the data
science field this is sort of known as
the split apply combined operation so
the complete left's we see our original
data frame we can see that we can split
up based on some column so maybe this is
gender maybe this is age group maybe
this is geolocation
whatever usually we're interested in
doing some sort of function per group so
let's say per gender we want to know the
average age for example and when we have
calculated that per group we want to
make a new table that's putting
everything back together so that's where
the apply a split apply combined comes
from this is a thing that is from the
are sort of world originally and it's
been incorporated into the pomace
library as well so we have that image
here as well if we all went to my
database my my blog right there's this
one
CSV file called chick wait it's about
chickens the goal for this dataset is
that there's a farmer and he has lots of
chickens and he gives different groups
of chickens different diets and what he
wants to find out is he wants to find
out which diet is the best to get the
chickens as fat as possible it's a basic
example but it's well suited for we want
to do because it immediately smells like
a split supply combined type of
operation what I'm doing right now is
I'm loading it in from my blog directly
so this read CSV file that pandas offers
to you can either open a file locally in
that case you just have to supply the
entire path and the file as a string it
can also open any resource on the web so
if you can point it to a CSV that's on
the web somewhere it will make a URL
request think at the data database which
you should also do is keep in mind that
it has an index column just called
grown-up so I suppose for you it should
look something like this
coming in probably in practice still
losing relatives passes a bit dangerous
if you're working with so in general
what we like to do is we like to hire a
server on Amazon and put like a huge
machine and do iPhone notebook through
some VPN connection in that case will be
nice if everyone from the same group is
using the same file so in practice if
you do it now perfect to the practice
yeah a little bit dangerous anyway given
that we have this new tricky data frame
loaded we're just gonna apply the same
things we saw before so this chicken
data frame we can apply the head
function on let's see what the data
frame actually looks like so let's maybe
just check the first ten rows and I can
see that I have a column with a chicken
ID in it I have a column with a diet ID
in it some sort of measurement of time
and some sort of measurement for weight
so okay this is probably a data frame
that we can use let's just quickly go
and check if the tail has different
information I looks I can see that
there's different ticks different diets
okay so the first step was we have to
split everything which basically means
we're going to group data frames by a
certain measure well in this case it
seems reasonable that we're going to
split the data frame up by diet this is
a farmer we want every chicken to get us
fat as quickly as possible so let's use
the diet because then we can calculate
maybe the weight per diet what happens
in Panos is that you have this group by
object a group by object is nothing but
a collection of tuples and data frames
here I'm saying the chick data frame
group this data frame by the diet column
this group item is something you can
iterate over so if everyone is here
if you have this in terms of usage
though for now we can see ah so this is
the first diet and we can see an entire
data frame here's the second diet third
day and the fourth day
a string so know what I'm doing so this
is a grouped object if you will and from
the looks of it it is a tuple where the
first index it might not actually be a
tuple to be honest this is sort of the
print representation so yeah so value of
the column data frame sorry for calling
they'd fit yes the cool thing about this
is just like before I could define any
function I can apply per group I can do
that here as well and this is sort of
the power of these data frames so what
you can see now is if I take this
grouped object and I try to describe it
for every other column that we had I get
this information for free and I end
again and I mean this with all series is
trying to do this in Excel you can also
define your own function but let's first
maybe I'm going too fast
so everyone is confirmed you can print
the grouped object you can look with and
describe the group object and once
you're there you can define your own
function something maybe like this I
could then take this grouped object and
apply any arbitrary function I defined
on that object this kind of that like a
functional programming paradigm is sort
of coming back here and also if you're
used to maybe Hadoop maybe the MapReduce
programming style this is very similar
so when I saw this the first time
basically this was my reaction because
just to take a couple of steps back this
any function in any group you can
specify so what this also means is I can
group by multiple columns at the same
time if I want to know per diet per time
unit what the weight was and apply a
mean on it sure it looks like a bit of a
chain but if I look at the API I know I
can quite clearly read what it's doing
it is a chicken data frame it's the CSV
file it's grouping it by these two
columns from it I take the way and I'm
applying a function towards it in one
line of code I've done a lot of steps
and it's very very readable especially
if you use the Python programming
already so the one the reason why I'm
focusing in on this and this means that
your documentation has been taken care
of for free simply if you just take the
Maya the pythonic approach here all the
data signs that you're doing with your
colleagues is documented because this
ipython notebook can be saved on a
server and it can be used for reference
whenever even as CSV files get updated
so suddenly we have a bit of automation
in this what you wanna do Barney yes
this okay could you
yeah I think technically so I defined a
function before which is called show
size technically this it works long
what this yeah of course it's like a
very ridiculous example but you can
imagine situations where in your own
company there's a very specific thing
that needs to get done to a certain data
frame and the only thing you have to do
now is make your own define function do
you guys remember how how hard it was to
make macros in Excel like that's free
here but alas I'm sort of raving on
about it is everyone's sort of done with
this because this is sort of the easy
steps for upon us I think hopefully I've
given you a good image of what Palmas
initially is trying to do and what it
sort of does we are not yet we are not
completely done with the entire sort of
data analytics thing we want to do
though because very very technically we
haven't visualized anything I cannot go
to my chief or my boss and say hey look
I've got a data frame everything
summarized we need to do a little bit
more and that's sort of our
visualization comes in now before I've
told you all the good parts about Python
like reasons why you would want to use
it there is a small reason why you might
not want to use it data science in
general is a young thing and data
science in Python is especially young
there's a programming language called R
that originated I think 10 to 15 years
ago and ours a programming language that
was founded only to do statistical
analysis with it so it's no surprise
that a very domain-specific thing in the
visualization of data came from that
field of programming up till today I
have not found a package that is so well
suited for visualization of data as
ggplot I have just spoken to the guys
from continuing the analytics and
they're working on this project called
bouquet it's very very promising and I
would love to see where it goes it's not
up to par ggplot yeah which is still why
I feel this is a good thing to learn and
I hope to convince you just by looking
at the API so this is the code you need
to make a line chart format plot lid
this is seriously how I feel about it if
I just want to make a line chart I
should not have to write 50-plus lines
of code and even the creator of pandas
degrees he is spoken about this so when
he says here in a statement on his blog
that he definitely agrees that ggplot2
is awesome
and he's actually hoping that someone
out there will make GD plot for Python
so we can wait for people to make this
it is never very easy to just take your
ipython notebook and only use R to make
these visualizations this one line of
code before we actually go and do that
let me just first show you why is a plot
to API is so powerful just in your own
head try to think with this so what
should this thing do in your own head
probably just make a point charge right
and again I don't want to be raving but
it's this versus this and this is only
the start so not only can I make the
basic charts very easily it's also very
flexible the next step would be to say
well what would this do and it's the
exact same code as before but the only
thing that's different is I've said size
is equal to 5 Oh bigger points ok so
that this is this this thing is also
kind of poetic in that you can read what
it does and it's only one line of code
so it ok this is kind of pythonic even
even though it comes from different
language this is nice what might this do
determined by the weight yes so as a way
and note that it doesn't have to be
another one what will this do
you should call or something right so we
were in the column we had IDs for
chickens basically the only thing that
this does is it gives a different color
for every chicken and it draws a
separate line for every chicken this is
free so again imagine doing this on
matplotlib
or excel for that matter and this is a
very flexible API so these are just
point graphs what a call so just do is
say I won't have a histogram but instead
of having it all one color I want the
fill to be determined by the diet so I
have a different color for free stacked
bar chart what I can also even do if I'd
really want to this is where it starts
to get kind of ridiculous the plotting
library GG plot is lazy that means that
which means like that as many aspects so
what I'm saying here is well I want to
make a histogram but after it put it in
a grid and with two lines of code it
will give me this so and again I cannot
imagine doing this with two lines of
code in matplotlib
we have another example in this case I
have a bunch of points that I'm drawing
and I'm doing something called Geum
smooth Geum smooth is also part of the
plumbing package and what it does it
just tries to smooth a pair of the
pattern that's in the data and visualize
it as well at the end what I do is I
give the graph a title I don't look like
this this is three lines of code so now
we get to the part on how we can pipe
bunless to arm the art language also has
a notion of a data frame object so
everything you've seen here in the code
is exactly how it's written in our the
only thing that we need to do is where
it says data equals economics that's
what we need to have a data frame but
there is a very good functionality for
piping a Python data frame to our so
what you will need is a module called
our pi/2 this is the module that allows
for the communication between you two
when R is installed in ipython you will
need to say hey be mindful also load R
in and you will then need to just push
the data frame and run our code within a
block one other thing you kind of need
to do as well this is why you needed to
download our studio and weather check
the time because at this point we're
hopefully going to experiment a bit more
I'm gonna walk around answering
questions if you've downloaded our
studio
make sure you've installed ggplot2
that's the plumbing library and once
you've done that we can go through all
these steps
so yeah I'll leave this open for now do
we
we have about 15 more minutes so what I
can do is either wait and have everyone
try and set things up or I can just show
you what I've got and you can ask me all
sorts of questions afterwards it's the
second one okay good so again remember
when I made the notion at the beginning
of my ipython notebook there was this
thing called load external are two pi
this basically means that I've loaded in
the thing that can communicate between R
and Python here I've previously
installed our two pi via pip
this is kind of a nice trick by the way
if you're using ipython notebook and you
don't know which anaconda you're using
you're using you can just use this one
function and it can install any package
within the virtual environment you're
actually using at the moment but alas
that once I have this the only thing I
need to do optimum to gnome is when I
have a Teta frame I use one block to say
well push this data frame to R and then
in another block everything that's
listed here is run in R because I'm
saying use this magic everything as
listening here is now an R function I'm
telling it well use a width of about
1200 pixels and take this chicken weight
data frame in I'm going to have to apply
a different screen size just to show it
but basically I have just used a Python
object pikelet to R and made this graph
again with just two lines of code I will
agree there's a bit of overhead that you
have to actually do these two steps but
it's nowhere near the overhead you need
one using matplotlib so just like before
I'm increasing the size and just like
before
I can do things with the weight and just
like before I can turn this diet into a
factor and also have every diet have its
own color while the weight is the thing
that's making the dose bigger and
smaller you've seen this chart before is
what's also kind of nice to note is
because of the laziness of the ggplot
module I can have points and lines just
blend it in into one graph and I've
histograms as well of course good person
and ggplot has the best documentation
I've ever seen in my entire life so just
go to TG plots to that org these are the
docs oh you mean that you can say help
file and and let's try it out okay I can
imagine it wouldn't have that support
fear not though because technically the
docs for GT par is so really good let's
say I just want to make the points so I
just go for point graph basically it's
everything you can possibly do with it
Plus every single chart as an example as
well so you can just cut and paste this
code into a point to know then it will
work so if I do this this should work on
the box
right
don't okay I'll have to get back on this
I think what I've not done as I need to
do this I'm going through this and now
it still doesn't know that I have shake
with ya that's odd if I do this there we
go
so all the examples that you see on this
website will work out of the box in arm
and because I work out of the box in
hard they will also work out of the box
inside of ipython notebook I will agree
that there is a bit the one thing that's
kind of annoying at this stage is that I
actually have to take that data frame
from Python and push it to our I would
like that's a very annoying aspect of it
the only reason is this is still so much
faster than using my public it's purely
because I find this very powerful there
is a project from Wyatt what they're
actually trying to do is to write a
layer of abstraction on that plot lib so
you can actually download a module
called ggplot for python it's actually
kind of a nice project so you can see
that the plots are actually very similar
in the way you would call it it's also
very similar it's just the docs are
still incomplete it's 0.5 version at the
moment as well so it's not near
something I would use in practice having
said that though typically what one
would do if you're doing this data
science is you would keep all the
aggregations still in Python such as you
can then push that aggregated data frame
into R and this is where things actually
do get quite interesting because what
you're looking at now
every time that I have here I have a
point and that makes it very easy have
just made this one ground and when
you're looking at this wrong instantly
becomes quite apparent if your tickets
as fast as possible issues the maybe
just I'm trying to say is don't
underestimate how powerful this was an
exciting day
ninety percent work will be ten percent
sex is most importantly they'll actually
get to the claim that the Alexa
convinced people are people and because
that is the sale step is so very
important to ever to use make any
compromises don't mind the best [ __ ]
librarians and also it doesn't really
hurt to learn a little bit are it's a
lot a lot of clients tend to use it then
sort of as a final exercise and then I'm
open to any questions and we can go and
hack it out a bit
there's a CSV file that I don't know
what it exactly does so these are so the
steps that one would take to analyze it
I would load it up and I would take it
into pandas I would push data frame to R
and I would see what the data frame X
actually is let's just check this so I
seem to have a data set there's
something of an x-axis there's something
of an R axis and there's something of a
y-axis let's see what is in it so one of
the axes is numeric the other one is
also numeric and the other one seems to
be characterized interesting let's see
if we can plot this so what I'm now
doing is I'm making a histogram for
every single factor that I have in this
column I use a different color and I can
see that hmm this seems to be sort of a
distinct distribution already on the X
values and I can do a similar thing on
the Y this is sort of interesting so at
this stage I kind of have no idea what
this day
three minutes but I can immediately see
that there's a pattern so also not just
at the end phase of doing that allows
the beginning phase it's actually quite
quite useful to be able to have a fast
exploratory tool becomes kind of more
apparent when I split it up so this is
definitely sort of a strange dataset
that is unless you plot the x and y axis
and then a different message in pattern
comes quite apparent so this is this was
the basically everything I wanted to
just go ahead and talk to you about
we still have well over 15 minutes from
the gist of it
so what I would like to propose is that
first if there are any questions we can
do those first and if not that then
everyone can use to go ahead and if
people want to take a break that's fine
as well but that you can then use me for
any random questions you might have
yes okay thank you first question for me
I guess
did you guys learn something new from
this because for the people who this was
new I definitely hope you kind of got
the idea of what panas is and why it's
cool and why planning is important how
you can combine the two things so as
long as you guys feel comfortable that
you've actually learned something today
then that's that was my main concern but
cool any questions yes good question
oh I actually have some slides how about
that there is a library but you still
have to install it if you have the art
studio it's very very easy it's just a
click if you don't have the art studio
there's kind of a pip like thing it's
called Ceylon but our studio thing is
the easiest thing one thing that's kinda
nice about our like I know people have
used it it is maintained by the academic
community so every package that you
download is basically its own machine
learning library and there's a guy with
six PhDs who's actually maintaining it
and he's actually the expert on the
field so that is a nice aspect of our
the only downside of it is is that it's
a fairly academic language because of
this as well
and therefore this most
we use only for statistics and that sort
of thing so I will never think about
building a server in our there are
people that are doing it but I think
they're insane yeah
having said that by the way if you're
interested in visualization there are
some other things you might want to look
at for machine learning there are these
things called so I could learn and PI
brain and PI MC and probably grid of
those but those are very good packages I
recommend you look at them they play
nice with panis as well
commercialization if you're not really
into ggplot I guess you can use
matplotlib I just checked out the guy
who made bouquet it looks interesting
it's not there yet but it's worth a look
definitely there's a thing called d3
which you might have heard of which is a
SVG library for visualizations Vincent
is a layer of abstraction for this so
you can use d3 type visualizations
within your ipython notebook it's pretty
good assesses your browser crashes if
you have more than a thousand SVG points
so only for small data there's a thing
called I graph which is good for a
visualization of graph types structures
and d3 in general is something you might
want to look at if you're doing any
visualizations for the front end wait
five minutes back then if you want to
know more I just took this with the
O'Reilly guy the leftmost book is
actually the best one and has been sold
out if you really are keen on learning
this the guy who made pandas actually
wrote the book and I can highly
recommend it you know it's it's an easy
read within a month you look better than
you can do everything if you're more
interested in learning Python in general
the mining the social web might be good
in that book what you will do is you
will download data from Facebook and
from LinkedIn and Twitter and try to do
something intelligent with it it's more
for if you're new to Python the machine
learning for hackers is also highly
recommendable that's more for the
scikit-learn so people who really want
to go into the machine learning but
that's something new you really want to
do yeah
it's that now I'm definitely done and
through all my slides any questions
No No
so here's the here's the problem with
the Vincent library at least in my
opinion so this is my blog and for those
of you that are Dutch you know what fin
dies okay so fin that is a website where
you can basically check every all the
house prices that are on sale you can
check the prices you can check how much
room there is in the house and etc it's
also very easy to parse so what you can
just do is you can download all the data
and you can then visualize it on the map
and give it a nice little color code to
basically say well this is a house I
might be willing to buy and this might
not be for me it was just sort of a
proof of concept so you can actually
show like probably one be living in a
city center but the main problem with
the Vincent library is I'm drawing quite
a lot of points here and these points
are in the end SVG graphics and SVG
object is an object that actually lives
in the Dom inside of your client it's
pretty okay if I only have below a
thousand or so of these SVG points but
as soon as I hit 2000 this browser has
kind of become very very laggy some
because it has a render so many things
and that's the problem with Vincent
library if you if you end up doing very
very large graphs like a scatterplot
with more than 2,000 points your browser
just might crash so that's my I still I
still think it's a nice library
I just wouldn't use it in production for
my personal uses I still prefer ggplot
the GG pot you mean or so just by
looking at our there's a bit of tweaking
there's a bit of hacking but our can
export let's just do two graphs if I
just check out what R has a
functionality I can copy this graph to
the clipboard I can save it as a PNG
image or I can even save it as a PDF
which also is basically an SVG image
everything I do here and basically runs
a line of our code in the back and that
our code can also be run in the ipython
notebook if you wanted to so you could
automatically save all of these charts
put it somewhere so that the server
might be able to render it but it's that
aspect is basically the same as
matplotlib the idea would then be
generate a new graph update an image
somewhere send that to the client does
this answer your question yeah if you
really wanted to you could yeah but it's
the same story I suppose the idea would
be that you would have some sort of a
update loop so once every minute or so
make these new plots and then the plots
would be updated somewhere and then that
will be the plot that will get retrieved
and if you have something with
WebSockets or something in town it also
sends something interesting to decline
you can update it automatically like
that but definitely at least my
knowledge then if there are no more
questions be free and of course if
thanks and of course it's our questions
I'll be right here
you